facebook has decided to uphold the ban
on donald trump and will reassess the
decision in a few months this was a
decision
we knew had been made a couple of days
ago by facebook's oversight board and it
was set to be announced this morning at
9 00 a.m
and as promised that right around 9 00
a.m eastern
the company's decision to suspend donald
trump
on both facebook and instagram was uh
confirmed and extended for at least a
period of several months
the board did rule that an indefinite
suspension of trump was not appropriate
so that time frame has now been amended
and the board said that they are going
to
re-review this at some period of time
in the relative future it seems as
though
um it will happen within six months the
board
asked that facebook complete the review
within six months
and said that maybe some clear policies
could be made to balance public safety
and freedom of expression remember that
originally the ban on donald trump from
facebook
uh different than the one on twitter i
mean every platform had their sort of
own justification
was that the risk to public safety
exceeded facebook's
purported uh desire to allow
freedom of expression and uh they
made that decision shortly after the
january sixth
trump riot insurrection of the u.s
capitol
this was the most aggressive action
facebook had taken against trump during
his entire four-year term
and mark zuckerberg the facebook ceo
said at the time quote
we believe the risks of allowing the
president to continue to use our service
during this period
are simply too great that decision
was then referred to the oversight board
several weeks later
because it was such a significant
decision they wanted the board to review
it and
independently judge whether trump should
remain banned
and now indeed they are saying it will
be i mean i guess
we're saying at least six months and
then it will be reviewed again
so depending on how you want to
interpret this news
trump continues banned and it's a
sledgehammer and cudgel against the free
speech of a former president
that's the way the right is reacting and
we'll have some of those
reaction clips maybe tomorrow depending
on what else is going on maybe not
on the other hand the news seems to be
signaling
that at some point trump is coming back
and my prediction would be
that if it's in six months or five or
seven or whenever
at a certain point the oversight board
at facebook
will determine that at this time
because things have simmered down or
whatever the case may be
at that time the um impetus
for providing a platform for expression
to a former president
will override in this kind of balancing
act the risk to public safety there will
still be a risk to public safety of
allowing trump back
on facebook but it will be overridden uh
given the circumstances at the time
now even though this is the news here is
they have decided the ban is no longer
indefinite they've announced it is no
longer a permanent ban
fox news couldn't even get the story
correct fox news went to air this
morning with a story called
facebook oversight board bans trump for
life that's
just inaccurate it's the opposite of the
decision i mean i guess
if you think trump won't live six months
i guess in a sense
trump may be banned for his life but
that is not
the story now it's obvious that
if allowed back on the platform donald
trump would
immediately resume using the platform
to spread corrosive lies and weaponized
disinformation the only question is
whether he should be allowed to do some
of that
because there should be emphasis placed
on allowing a former president to use
these platforms to communicate
even in a situation where someone else
a sort of mere mortal so to speak you
know a civilian a normal person
would not be allowed to do that and
that's a question that the facebook
board
will answer presumably in about uh
six months now in terms of
um what we're going to get later
actually
to donald trump's desire to communicate
directly with the public he has launched
now
this much promoted new communication
platform
it's just a blog and we're going to get
to that later but there is no question
that
you know six months from now we will be
well into the 2022 campaign i know it
sounds insane because
trump still hasn't accepted the results
of 2020 trump still hasn't even accepted
the popular vote results of 2016.
but six months from now we will be
uh under a year out from the midterms
and so
trump's desire to play king maker and to
determine
who is a real republican as far as he's
concerned that is going to be riding
very high
in six months which will be early
november of 2021.
so there's no question that we're going
to be hearing more from trump by then
one way or another the question is
whether we will be hearing from him on
facebook for now trump remains banned
but it is no longer an indefinite ban
and we'll have more on that
as needed maybe tomorrow or maybe not
one of our sponsors is vincero watches
giving you 15
off a high quality wristwatch is the
perfect way to
elevate your style own at least one
watch
that makes you feel great when you put
it on you can often see me wearing
my ventura watch on the show mine is the
gunmetal
vessel model i'm a big fan of the
metallic look
of the face of the watch i like the
silicone strap
you won't find a better made watch for
this good a price
anywhere else when you put it on you
know you got more than you paid for
vincero believes in crafting super
quality watches from high-end materials
but selling them at fair prices which is
why they have over 26
000 five-star reviews and they stand
behind
every watch they make with a one-year
return policy and
five-year warranty they'll give you
fifteen percent off everything in their
store
and free shipping at davidpakman.com
watch use the coupon code pacman